وصفه الرئيس التركي بانه صندوق اسراره كان
اول من علم باحتماليه حدوث انقلاب 2016
وزير الخارجيه كان افيدان ابرز وزراء
اردوغان الجدد صامت وغامض لا مقابلات
تلفزيونيه ولا مؤتمرات صحفيه سابقه قبل
حقيبه الخارجيه تعرف باردغان عام 2003
تشابهت الرؤى عوده تركيا لاحضان الشرق
وتعزيز قوتها الناعمه في دول اسيا الوسطى
والقوقاز
اصبحت عمليات مكافحه التجسس التي تقوم بها
الوكاله الوكاله الاستخباراتيه التركيه
اكثر بروزا خلال رئاسه فيدان تم القبض على
خلايا تجسس تابعه لكل من اسرائيل وروسيا
وايران ولطالما كان منصب وزير الخارجيه في
تركيا بمثابه خطوه اخيره قبل الوصول لراس
السلطه سواء كرئيس او رئيس الوزراء
الامثله كثيره من عصمت اينينو ومسعود
ايلمز وصولا الى عبد الله غول واحمد داوود
اوغلو فهل كانت خطوه اردوغان باخراج بدانه
من رسم السياسه الخارجيه في الظل الى
النور تمهيدا لاعلان خليفته
حكومه اردوغان ما زالت حديثه الشارع
التركي فهي من اكثر حكومات التكنوقراط
التي شكلها الرئيس التركي لكن هناك اسماء
لاقت اهتماما خاصا طبعا في مقدمتهم فيدان
رجل الدوله القوي او رجل الظل رئيس
الاستخبارات السابق ووزير الخارجيه الحالي
شكل فيدان محور النفوذ التركي في اذربيجان
وليبيا وعده دول وتراس اجتماعات تطبيع
العلاقات مع بعض دول المنطقه لديه علاقات
جيده مع روسيا وايضا مع الغرب لذلك ينظر
اليه انه ميزان العلاقات التركيه ما بين
الشرق والغرب لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات